yeah welcome to this video I'm playing a
loser nine one eight eight huh okay from
India it's a very high rating oh it's a
brand-new account okay eight wins and so
on okay that's a bit of a joker you
never know based on eight nine games how
strong they really are so we're going to
yeah so it's a bit of a surprise thing
and let's see what happens okay it's
playing the rest of opening here and
this is this kind of way to play it is
bit outdated when f3 and you for general
consensus is that this this line is
pretty good for black but yeah we will
see what happens it's a bit surprising
that he's going for that okay in this
particular case okay at least he's he
you want a pawn no that's not that's not
bad but of course I have a pretty decent
compensation on the dark squares so what
am I playing here an interesting
question after Queen to d2 is it a case
where I should keep Queens on or where
should where I mean I can definitely
trade and have compensation the question
is should I do that they go like Queen
g6 there's this Bishop h6 idea hmm okay
but he will probably be able to castle
short that's a tricky decision okay I'm
going to keep the Queen's on but that
wasn't a simple simple decision lets him
so what is this he wants to play Knight
f4 I am
okay
and then g3 yeah that makes sense
so it already looks a little bit like I
should have played the Queen trade it's
not not that obvious way I'm going with
the Queen she page six Knight f4 Queen
f6 yeah okay I should have traded and I
should have really thought a bit more
about it really with concrete move was
not just some gut feeling decision I
would have seen knighted - I would have
discarded that
that's not looking good there and he's
got night age five this is this kind of
idea after that he goes the immediately
Sun okay let's go here yeah I should
have traded twins that would have just
been okay I mean no particular problem
for me then okay so he might have G four
at one moment but okay nothing I can do
about it at the moment night C forest
animals trying to irritate his Queen a
bit yeah maybe he has to give up the
bishop damn and I which is not the end
of the world admittedly and this got G
for now no he doesn't g3 okay so maybe
get something going here
looks a bit loosening no egos she for
what what kind of place that weird okay
I can go g IG v I can take c3 and then
what a queen is trapped
oh yeah Queen III uh-huh
yeah welcome to the world of chess
engines we've got another cheater on our
hands here and III first and g4i yeah
sure everything is cool baby
okay you got he got Ben soon black
reason okay now let's let's have a look
there and see the engine correlation so
it's a pretty typical mo for cheaters to
play those crab openings and then then
come from there okay Teague's jigs Queen
d2 yeah I should tre I should take now
that's really the China moves I mean I
definitely have compensation for the
pawn in terms of the bishop pay I always
have that check which should be six long
castles the computer even gives black an
advantage so this is no problem at all
but after Queen g6 I really didn't
calculate 92 is a good move note by the
way that she always takes those for 5
seconds per move the sista the the
giveaway that it is an engine long
castles short castles h4 that's normal
engine but it's all pretty simple of
course and this should be 2 or some
computer move B should be 6 king v1 is
also given by the comp 9 c4 takes takes
me and then g3 this is this is funny g3
is also the engine move of course you go
b5 and then then it will go g4 probably
g4 okay before which is which is bad I
mean I played a very bad game but takes
23 and I'm done yeah ok I'll send a
message to Edmonds he will get banned
everything's cool but I still don't get
the point what if people were people do
that it's he has got a 100% engine
nation here at least with my my
stockfish version here and it all looked
very computer ish the whole thing like
g3 then g4 and and the whole thing like
hair playing this bad opening and so on
and all fits very very well okay I'm
going to report them and we'll see what
happened what happens but yeah I don't
know I'm going to upload it anyway but
yeah at least it's got a fitting name
loser 9 188 that's cool
okay well thanks for watching